So let's discuss the speedup numbers we can
get. We have already seen in the previous
quizzes that a speedup larger than one means
improved performance. Either through shorter execution time it takes
less to compute something than before, or higher
throughput, we can do more of something per
second than before. A speedup of less than
one means that we have worse performance than before.
Either it takes longer to execute something, or
we get lower throughput that before. And finally, when
computing speed up, remember that performance is proportional
to throughput. So when computing speed up, we divide
the throughput of the new thing with the
throughput of the old thing. However, performance is proportional
to 1 over latency. So, if we have
something like, it takes two seconds to do something,
that's a latency. Performance in this case is 1 over that. So,
when computing speedups, we actually divide
the old latency with the new latency.